at the very least it is particularly
awkward this happened about four hours
ago now we knew that William would be
coming to this part of the far southwest
of China he turned up here for
effectively a photo opportunity Palace
officials wanted him to be seen with an
elephant the only place you'll find
elephants apparently in the wild in
China is here in Yunnan Province so he
did the photo opportunity he was with an
elephant but what we discovered was that
a kilometer away within the same area
twice a day daily there is a show in
which elephants perform doing all sorts
of things from standing on small stools
to wearing giant spectacles tourists are
encouraged to sit on their trunks just
before the show starts I managed to film
a bit of footage of them the elephants
shackled by their legs some of them had
bare their tusks sawn off halfway down I
guess that's simply because those tusks
can be very very dangerous that's why
they be sawn off but it's a really
awkward position to have William on one
hand here trying to tell that the
Chinese that they really need to do more
in the conservation of wildlife and
everyone would agree that the Chinese
are the main protagonists in the they
trade in illegal wildlife now it's worth
stressing that there's no suggestion
that these particular elephants are in
any way involved in the trade in illegal
wildlife its African elephants which the
Chinese hunt and then take the tusks
back to China but nevertheless it's an
awkward position an awkward
juxtaposition I know that Palace
officials and officials in the Foreign
Office were here at the sanctuary
exactly a month ago looking into the
logistics where he was gonna be where he
was going to be where he's going to
stand the whole thing is highly
choreographed so they must have known or
if not they they just how they missed it
I don't know that this show was going on
I did try I think breaking royal
protocol somewhat to ask the prince
whether he was aware at this it was this
was hat that this was happening here's
what he said or didn't say
you're all highness have you been told
about the performing elephants next door
the Chinese are using elephants to play
football you're all highness we're not
going to get any more from Prince
William as I understand it but I have
spoken to Royal officials if I die
mention it to them before I asked the
prince I said you know about this this
show and they said yes we're vaguely
aware of it but after I doubt that was
before I'd I've been to it myself I then
sat through the whole thing and I spoke
to a senior press a senior palace
official and told her what I'd seen and
she said yes that they had they were now
aware of it
but they're trying to spin this and say
look William is here effectively on a
fact-finding mission he wants to
understand how the Chinese deal with
conservation issues but what effectively
we've got here is a park an animal park
called the wild wild elephant Valley
where on the one hand yes they're trying
to conserve the few elephants that they
have left but on the other hand the same
organization is drawing in hundreds of
tourists today by making the elephants
perform